so i was searching vaynerchuk with a c
because i know so many people search it
that way and i know i should be using uh
you know twit deck and all that stuff
but i'm old school and i came across
tish greer saying hmm on tuesday gary
vaynerchuk railed
old media's dead and the same this am
he's on
the today show what a hypocrite must
have a good agent
now tish i get it but i just want to
clear something up you know
i'm not saying that old media is dead
today i am saying that i believe they're
going to have a tough time selling their
advertising ratios which is where they
make their money
considering the ri roi considering the
eyeballs are stretching and going in
different places
um you know considering that a 1.0 now
is a good rating
uh nielsen's one used to be at least a
10 and i don't think i'm being a
hypocrite i'm trying to help or
who might help but i'm just saying i'm
trying to voice my opinion that i do
believe that everybody can be a content
provider
don't give up a lot of the percentage do
your own thing follow your passion
and that television and newspaper and
the gatekeepers are losing a little bit
of their competitive edge
um i don't see how that's being a
hypocrite going on building my brand
using that i'll use anything i'll go
fly in a kite that being said after tish
said that and
by the way i highly respect tish's point
of view because
that's what's up i respect it um then
derek followed up uh
tish's uh response by saying um
at tashkrier i have never understood
gary vaynerchuk other than having a big
mouth i've never found much value
what he says so a couple good lessons
one always search your name
maybe there's different ways people
spell your name not every name is as
difficult as vaynerchuk and number two
um a lot of people email me and say they
don't have the charisma i have
they're not extroverted they're not this
they're not that well guess what you are
what you are
introverted quiet maybe poised probably
a lot more polished we all have our
different styles
own yours because look just because i'm
over the top and exciting and you love
that
well clearly derek allard thinks that
i'm a jerk probably or two over the top
or
have no substance behind me being so
excited
and i respect that though i think derek
is wrong because
you know i've proven a couple of chops
here and there but i've got a lot more
to prove and i respect that
two things definitely one always search
what's going on about yourself because
you want to get a pulse of what people
think
i think you shouldn't care what anybody
thinks and you should care what
everybody thinks
think about that and number two um i i
think that it's very important
to always always always interact
respect of other people's feelings and
counter them just like i'm doing now on
garyvaynerchuk.com
i'm countering because i think tish is
wrong i don't think being a hypocrite
when i see something
is out there and trying to help the
people that are in that industry get out
and start building their personal brand
so when they get fired by the newspaper
when they lose their inventory
and their their advertising dollars that
they actually have something to do
and build on uh you know just to go on
today's show no that's helping me build
my brand that's what i do
and number two derek jumps in there and
i respect that um
and i think it's important for a lot of
people that feel like they're introverts
and don't have as much charisma or
whatever the heck they think
that they should know that there's
plenty of people that are going to
respect and appreciate their style
a lot more than my style but i think
that what you should really do is get
out there
have a pulse of what the market's saying
do what you believe in
talk about what you believe in crush
your content own
you and uh but own you
unabashedly just own you but respect
others and i respect
tish and derek and i'll link up these
tweets because
i see that the flip cam might not be
that clear and i wish you all
a great day